usually when we rank a president we're
just sort of looking at them as a set of
policies that's what we seem to do
nowadays which is kind of bizarre
because this is a person who's supposed
to be a leader in character does mean
something when you're a leader
but with joe biden it's not just that
all of his policies have been horrible
for the country it's that
he
is experiencing serious cognitive
decline like the man's brain
let's do it we got this story from the
new york post oh you're so excited
you take your seat very specific cheat
sheet reminds button how to act look at
this in this why did he hold it up i
think in order
no you're the president joe biden was
speaking he was holding up a card and it
says you enter the roosevelt room and
say hello to participants you take your
receipt like you is in big bold letters
and yours in big bold letters like dude
there's something wrong with this guy's
brain you tell ukraine that the funds
will be withheld
maybe someone played a joke on him at
number five was you hold card up to
camera and he's like okay all right here
i go come on man you know you think
about joe and and his cognitive you know
and i tell you what there's one person
that i'm really really frustrated with
and i think that
it it's jill biden
listen she's been married to this guy
for years she knows him better than
anybody you like throwing the [ __ ] well
i'm just saying that you know what i
don't know if it
she wanted to be the first lady so bad
and and have that power or she wanted to
make sure that her husband reached that
pinnacle but i'm really frustrated with
her because she knows her husband better
than anybody and she knew he was going
to be like this but she didn't care and
now the american people are paying for
this thing because of what her because
she wanted to see her husband accomplish
something or maybe this was more about
her becoming you know the first lady but
uh she she
shameful
shameful i mean the democrats hated
trump so much i remember
everybody i used to hang out with we
weren't fans of biden biden was part of
the corporate left and suddenly these
same people were doing everything in
their power to elect a guy who they knew
we knew i didn't vote for him but we
knew would not be
good i don't know it'll be this bad but
yeah well
same deal it's like we were
hating the clintons forever and now
you're acting like you're a sexist if
you're not going to vote for it occupy
wall street was anti-obama the people
down there were like obama's trash yep
and then it's like 2016 comes around and
they're like we've forgotten all about
that we like him now
hope and change baby yep yep yep yeah no
that's a very good point about joe biden
though i mean she should know right this
man has literally lost his mind is lost
it's just why did they pick it it's
insane doctor jill i'm sorry um
they used to joke about reagan and they
would say you know towards the end of
reagan's presidency he experienced some
cognitive decline and that was sort of a
little jab they'd make it republicans
look a person you elected back when they
were mentally healthy ended up
experiencing cognitive decline how
irresponsible is your party that he
wasn't immediately removed from power
during the primaries
joe biden was clearly demented or
suffering with alzheimer's his brain
was not functioning at like any point
and i i say this like look if i was
discussing any other senior citizen
experiencing cognitive decline i would
probably take a more somber approach to
this like but this is the president yeah
they knew this they put the man in this
position knowing his brain
does not work stop being aegis and
ableist sheamus
i know you're right no we're we're
trying to defend them oh that's true
yeah whenever they show like obama and
they're like this is how he looked in
the beginning of his presidency and then
they show him with gray hair it's like
yo joe biden started looking ralph where
does that go yeah sheamus you're right i
mean this is the leader of the free
world yeah that we have as our president
united states and the media covers for
him you know i mean we have gas at five
bucks i mean i've said it how many times
and he's taken b walks on the beach but
he's got to have his handlers if it's
not the bunny rabbit during easter it's
the grandchildren and the other saying
come on honey we got to go we got to
pull you over here let me
real quick i want to give a shout out to
the onion
from this article oh stress of
presidency already ages but in 10 years
oh my god
you gotta give them where credit is
he should really be ashamed of this
inflation and gas being five bucks a
year i think it was like two cents a
gallon when he was a kid right
they were still dinosaurs when he was a
kid to be fair they were still walking
around yeah yeah had been crushing the
crude oil but no it's shameful it's
dinosaurs aren't oil sheamus i know it's
the plant life and that was uh but
people say diet you know we don't
support the fake news on this show i
know you're right
thank you thank you ministry of truth
you're gonna sing a musical about
yeah exactly he's very my joke was that
i didn't mean to spread misinformation
about oil i'm saying that joe biden is
old all right
okay he's old everybody
yeah tim is getting on me for being um
factually inaccurate when i'm morally
correct well i was reading snopes
earlier and i was just thinking like i
shouldn't let sheamus get away with
these jokes this misinformation this
misinformation yeah no it's it's
troubling and i think you know there's
something to be said for the fact that
no joe biden is not the sole culprit
here but he was part of the
establishment that led to all of these
problems it's not like he's just some
fall guy who had nothing to do with this
that that card he's holding up we are
literally in weekend at biden's i know
someone would just like
it wouldn't be funny if someone was
always standing next to him just like un
unreasonably close you're like what's
going on do you see their arms you can't
see their arm what was what was his one
word that described america do you
remember this
like there's one word it describes it
it's the book
guys maybe that's why he's getting so
close to the kids as the kids are
whispering him as lines he forgot oh i
see what it is so there you go i figured
it out you're welcome joe biden i like
that let's see the the press secretary
tell us that oh here we go it's
something that they can yeah
here we go here we go hold on guys this
is important it's very important
america's oh wait i gotta fix this
i always have the audience that's the
wrong thing because you guys need to
know
you guys need to hear there we go you
ready
that can be defined in a single word
what oh this poor old guy
here's the thing
yeah i would feel bad for him if like
all right first of all if he wasn't a
horrible person doing horrible things
who should have stepped down
and also if you saw like being gaslit
about this he's got the he has a speech
impediment excuse me that's what a lisp
does no wrong incorrect his brain is not
functioning
so he's a plagiarist some british
politician probably had this gaffe first
that'd be funny why why are they even
talking about a second term though yeah
he's actually i don't think he's denied
it
he's he's claiming he's gonna run yeah
so think about that now that the current
condition he's in in another three years
insane that is insane yes are they just
hoping that this country is so
tribalized that people will vote for him
well that's what happened the first time
well the first time people hated trump
maybe they're hoping they can do a
repeat but i really doubt it i think the
five bucks per gallon thing really irked
some people yeah i like the joke i was
making earlier i really doubt you're
gonna go to a gas station and someone's
gonna be like
screaming and it turns out they're
screaming over january january 6th yeah
no it's it's a suit for her
now there's there was actually breaking
news uh biden plagiarized his gaffe from
a british politician the one thing we
can say about england
and nana
trinidad nice shopping of pressure
under pressure
true to that shop at a pressure do you
remember that remember remember that one
troy no i can't say i have but i i do
know this is that
they actually feel that uh that he has a
chance when he comes back i really
believe that uh that if he would seek
another term
and if you look at what happened with
the election in 2020 and the way that
thing was handled and managed and you
get started giving everybody ballots and
yeah
you could see i mean
i i wasn't afraid i'll need an effective
strategy to mobilize true and
international depression oh boy i wish i
would have an effective strategy to
mobilize true international effort to
pressure now the best part is they're
clapping like when he says it yes we
need turner today but a pressure he said
batacaf care yeah he's loud there he's
trying to demonstrate strength by yeah
very vocal and like he's a hard charger
they probably could never essentially
saw that he's like i can have ukraine
next now resent batacaf care shouldn't
done a shop at a pressure and a
certificate they probably think it's new
progressive terms and they don't want to
get in trouble if they don't clap it's
like latina x they're like okay that's a
new one it doesn't end in another shake
he created a new incomprehensible
language
old man is just up there
muttering to himself and people are
clapping for it yeah
that's why i'm like i don't know i'm
kind of i'm kind of a pessimistic on
this one he's an innovator of language
baby the american people are going to
vote for that
that's scary well the polls have shown
what is he 32-33 percent
and so the real question is
the way 30 i got to talk to those i know
i know that's right i don't know about
the 30
yeah are they where are they and what
are they thinking i i cannot imagine 30
percent of the country you know yeah
this guy's doing a great job they don't
drive cars they're the ones who are all
working at the mainstream media we
should we should do a bit
where you know jamie's just like i
actually i actually think trinidad shop
and pressure is a good thing yeah what
is that like it's a good thing it's a
it's a great thing that's a great thing
and it's uh it's diversive and bad at
calf care we love better care better
i've i've always supported medical care
you know i mean when noam chomsky talked
about out of it
supported it then i'll support it now
but i wonder if just like how do they
answer this do they act like it doesn't
exist yeah well no they they say he has
a speech impediment he has a lisp that's
what they constantly claim when people
make fun of him
yes yeah also that's scary again
commander in chief of the military
probably shouldn't be mislabeling
countries like that a little bit
frightening
he's going to be talking to the joint
chiefs but we got to bomb libya and
they're like are you sure yeah and then
they're like okay
and then later they're like why are why
is the us engaged in a military conflict
in libya and biden's going to be like oh
no i met syria
the media the media corrects for him
they translate for him they're like
they're like they're like we dropped the
bomb on libby's like go pick it up man
put it drop on siri instead buy them
why'd you sniff that kid i have a lisp
yeah come on man he has a lisp you
heartless person yeah they will like
scold you for is hilarious people have
been scolded for criticizing him uh i
can't remember who this was it was on
one of these news networks you know
msnbs or cnn or whatever and they're
going how
how how do you think children with lisps
are going to feel
when they see the way you're making fun
of the president or they're the the
potential president for the way he
speaks he's like what that's not no a
lisp does not make you say poor kids are
just as bright and talented as white
kids that's not how a lisp works
well well uh
now according to the dsm-6
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast but if you
want to check out the full show live
tune in monday through friday at 8pm and
if you want more special access content
head over to timcast.com and become a
member your membership helps sustain
this company keep our journalists
employed makes this show happen and you
will get access to exclusive members
only segments of the tim cast irl
podcast and there is a massive library
to check out so again go to timcast.com
or tune in monday through friday at 8 pm
we'll see you all there
you